c'est bien et j'accueille maintenant
florence moncorgé gabin
très séduisant anc laurence wiart dit
est un très très à part lui je vois pas
qui peut être le groupe canon bon alors
meilleur vous connaissez pas ce que vous
avez été script florence sur un film ou
jouer pierre arditi je crois que c'était
de guerre lasse avec nathalie baye
d'ailleurs et christophe malavoy et
alors page 68 de votre livre vous faites
un tombereau de compliments sur laon
souvenez pas j'ai un peu non j'ai pas lu
le livre et vous allez voir ce qu'elle
dit oui où la vie de guerre lasse et
unis c'est sur le même plateau nathalie
baye pierre arditi christophe malavoy et
jean bouise et cetera
robert était un bulldozer robert enrico
à le réalisateur seul arditi nager comme
un poisson dans l'eau
il est des acteurs qui n'ont besoin ni
d'encouragements ni d'indication qui ne
sont influençables ni par les colères et
les sautes d'humeur du metteur en scène
ni par les impondérables du tournage les
vieux routiers du métier c'est moins
sympa lui personnalités taillé dans le
roc pas les nature dans le jeu et sur
net car et précis aussi à l'aise le
premier jour de tournage que le dernier
formellement c'est quand même
whittier le tien amoureux joel ward et
oui à les accords tout fait à tu ne peux
pas me le dire bon dieu merci ternois à
l'époque et moi aussi
on avait ce trait on a un extrait du
film vous l'avez le lamentable parce que
je viens de faire
lamentable mais c'est lamentable très
bien alors france bonsoir dont vous êtes
la fille de jean gabin et vous publié
aux éditions du cherche midi
un livre qui s'appelle quitte à avoir un
père autant qu'ils s'appellent gaba
alors votre bouquin à florence et pas
une bio de jean gabin y en a eu à celle
de brunelin qui est très célèbre c'est
pas non plus une autobiographie de votre
part c'est plutôt des souvenirs
en fait c'est un livre que vous avez
écrit au départ pour votre mère pour
raconter un petit peu laissé une trace
de ce que vous aviez vécu ensemble avec
avec jean gabin ce que les biographies
non non pas raconter et malheureusement
vous avez rendu votre manuscrit au
cherche midi la veille de son décès dont
elle n'a jamais lu mais vous avez le
temps de lui en parler quand même oui en
fait en fait j'ai écrit ce livre parce
que je voulais qu'on s'amuse toutes les
deux ensemble à à lire ses livres après
parce qu'il y avait tellement de deux
d'anecdotes croustillantes sur mon père
des choses que les gens ne veux pas
imaginer et on en parlait tellement
ensemble que je me suis dit bon ben on
va on c'est vrai on va écrire ça et puis
on va tous s'amuser bon elle n'aura pas
eu mais enfin mon frère l'a lu les
proches de la famille ont lu et ils ont
tous bien bien ri alors jean gabin et
efficience et pas très bien d'une
chanteuse de café-concert et son père
était comédien d'opérette et il a
commencé gabin comme boy aux folies
bergères survie alors c'est comme ça
qu'il a épousé une dénommée gars du bas
sais vous avez rencontré d'ailleurs un
qui venait dé foi chez vous vous aviez
chez elle commence oui j'ai des vagues
souvenirs quand j'ai un petit mais c'est
une femme charmante
ils s'étaient mariés il avait 18 ans il
y avait prescription alors la deuxième
épouse de votre père c'était dorian une
danseuse nue à l'époque des folies
bergère à aider les cas d'arrêt ensuite
il a eu michel morgant marlene dietrich
enfin et c est les femmes les plus
belles du monde
ils sont tombés dans les bras et ils son
troisième mariage c'était votre maire
dominique fournier qui était mannequin
chez chez lanvin lors une anecdote
extraordinaire comme ans avant de se
marier avec votre père
elle n'était pas encore chez lanvin et
eicher m la vie passée dans la rue c'est
ça non oui elle m'a elle m'a raconté
cette histoire très amusante c'est à
dire quel était l est et je crois même
vendeuse chez hermès en prenant elle pas
encore
mannequin et tout d'un coup il ya un
attroupement et tout lé tout le
personnel de chez hermès s'est précipité
devant sur les carreaux le nez collé aux
vitres il y avait une usine qui passait
avec gabin et marlène dietrich une
décapotable et elle dit comme comme
toutes les midinettes je me suis
précipité pour voir gabin et marlène
passé sans penser qu'un an plus tard je
serai mariée avec galles foule dans
l'histoire alors quand vous laissez
votre père est fou de joie parce qu'ils
croyaient qu'ils pouvaient pas avoir
d'enfant
en fait il n'a eu 3 vous évidemment
votre soeur valérie votre frère mathias
et à partir de là gabin a été saisi par
une espèce d'anxiété une espèce
d'angoissé la responsabilité familiale
c'était peut-être quelque chose qu'ils
ne voulaient pas en tous les cas c'était
très lourd pour ses épaules d'après ce
qu'on lit dans votre livre
mais je pense que c'était quelque chose
à laquelle ils n'étaient pas préparés
quoi qu'il en avait terriblement envie
mais il y en avait très peur et
bon il un enfant peut-être il aurait pu
assumer l'un d'eux poids mais vous savez
que ma mère aurait continué s'il avait
paraît il a dit stop
1 serait peut-être six ou sept ans
maintenant ouais mais c'était une
responsabilité non pour lui il avait du
mal à faire face
ouais c'est ça la vie en france s etc il
était comme devant des jouets dont il ne
connaît pas le mode d'emploi
alors d'abord il envoie votre mère en
clinique
huit jours avant l'accouchement quand
même beaucoup et cela vous dit cela ne
faisait que commencer car l'an boisse et
l'anxiété serait l'essence même de son
caractère et elle est joué un rôle
déterminant dans son comportement futur
transformer le séducteur décontracté en
père de famille responsable et en
horrible misanthrope c'était aka partir
de là effectivement il se referme
complètement sur lui même et je me mets
à la place de de votre mère qui avait
connu ce séducteur flamboyant qui d'un
seul coup se retrouve avec un petit
vieux la maison quoi pas un petit vieux
si vous dites qu'elle s'il souhaitait
vieillir prématurément et la souffrance
de ma mère dit vous ton père se fait
plus vieux qu'il ne s'avère souvent il
s'est recroquevillé sur lui même et
c'est terry vous épouser quelqu'un de
séducteur et d'un coup vous vous
retrouvez avec quelqu'un en charentaises
à la maison et se soldent voyez c'est
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est à chaque
enfant il a pris du ventre et il est
devenu un monsieur respectable et je
pense d'ailleurs que ça lui a permis de
faire sa seconde can oui et s'il était
resté avec bien sûr tente du séducteur
il est extraordinaire c'est qu'en fait
ils étaient dans la vie comme nous on le
voyait au cinéma d'une certaine façon
espèce de pépé bourgon alors très
angoissée d'abord il était obsédé par
l'idée que les enfants aillent pas aux
toilettes ça semble bizarre mais oui
parce que si vous voulez j'étais sans
moi j'ai des enfants je veux m'occuper
tous deux entendus je les aime et donc
mais vous regardez si vos toilettes non
important alors mais non enfin sur moi
c'est parce que vous vous intéressez pas
assez vos enfants
je vous y passez que moi j'avais une
grand mère qui ne jugeait qu'il ne nous
jugez bien que si nous allions aux
toiles et en fonction de ce que nous y
avions fait nous avions fait la petite
commission on était des gens moyens et
c'est la grosse commission d'état des
gens très bavard et en très bien jean
gabin bas âge au gab à 37,2 de
température les enfants n'est pas
l'école par exemple 37,2 nettoie et puis
alors il était très attentif comme ça
très très très méticuleux très
pointilleux même temps il faisait
rarement des câlins et des bisous
j'aime mais j'ai vu mon père me prendre
dans les bras même le matin quand on
arrivait pour y prenez il était toujours
à son bureau le matin avec son café et
ses clopes ce qu'il avait toujours ses
clubs arrivent en lui alors on lui
faisait le bisou et c'est tout moi tu as
bien dormi pas comment ça va et ou alors
prendre par la taille moi je fais ça
avec mise en scène prend par la taille
sur leur dire bonjour et lui n'ont alors
en arriver en dire bonjour à la queue
leu leu qui ont parfois c'était fini
pour la journée quand on le voit dans
des films avec des enfants par exemple
il ya quelques films tournés avec des
arrivants et on voit bien qu'il est
l'enfant est un être étrange et plus et
même s'il devient tendre dans le film
avec l'enfant il signe tendresse
toujours un peu comme c'est un peu viril
un peu alors dit non le machin bon et il
tire à faire ça tire habilement maire
veut pas penser comme ça et peut-être
qu'après tout ça n'était que le reflet
comme une foule beaucoup d'acteurs on va
tirer dans nos vies ce qu'on ramène sur
l'écran et donc du soleil à apprendre
dans savais qu'il y avait une certaine
timidité visuels nous je suppose que
c'est une timidité
parce qu'il nous aurait pris nous avons
nourri nous aurait dit quoi il fallait
tout deviné c'est sûr qu'il y avait de
l'amour mais il fallait diminuer alors
bon il y avait cinq à l'arrivée des
manies incroyable c'est à dire que
présente patil écrasé une cigarette tue
écrasé pendant une pompe comme ça pour
être sûr que tu es bien l'état tout ou
le gaz a legacy le gaz était bien éteint
il se relever la nuit où c'est ça c'est
de voir gabaye quand même le mec quoi
l'homme a vu cinéma français
quand même assez tel chef chef du clan
et alors il se relever la nuit pour
aller voir si c'était bien faire mais
cette série mais parce qu'ils devraient
terriblement malheureux
avec cette anxiété c'est horrible alors
quand on essaye de comprendre d'où ça
vient il ya effectivement le fait qu'il
avait vécu deux guerres déjà donc la
première évidemment c'était très dur
pour lui la deuxième où il s'était
comporté d'une façon extrêmement
héroïque et brillante évidemment et
ensuite il y avait eu cette traversée du
désert après la guerre parce qu'il avait
refusé de faire les portes de la nuit de
prévert et carmet et ces montants qui a
fait des portes de la nuit ils disent
est ce une belle connerie d'heure lui
n'était pas à wil a dit la villa 17 une
belle connerie mais à l'époque il devait
le faire avec marlene dietrich et c'est
parler et s'est séparé d'elle 1 donc bon
belle fille ne s'est pas fait du tout
avec ensuite aussi ce qui peut expliquer
son angoisse et ses problème c'est
qu'après la guerre il avait eu cette
traversée du désert disons cette éclipse
et sa carrière n'a redémarré qu'en 53
avec touchez pas au grisbi donc quand
même passé pas mal d'années comme ça sur
le vous est arrivé vous ça non non
jamais enfin il faut pas oublier quand
même que gabin a fait la guerre comme un
sapin d'acteur mais pas un grand nombre
d'acteurs un gabin il ya jean pierre
aumont y avait quelques autres mais sont
ils sont vraiment comporté envers ou
alors ils ont ils l'ont jamais ramené
parce que c'était des gens simples et
qu'il n'est pas mais enfin gabin il
s'est comporté comme un héros un ferme
en ferme et clair alors il était il
était très inquiet sur l'avenir aussi
c'est à dire que par exemple il
considérait que le cinéma c'est une une
profession provisoire un métier de
maboule comme vous le racontez et il
avait confiance dans la terre c'était
vraiment comme ça ils disaient légaux
seront à bouffer il pensait pas que le
cinéma allait lui permettre d'élever ses
enfants très longtemps et oui parce que
comme il avait eu cette traversée du
désert il s'est dit un jour ou l'autre
on va pu me demander
ouais bon ça y est je crois que c'est
inhérent à tous comédiens s'adressent
que tous les comédiens ont toujours peur
que le téléphone ne sonne plus bon là il
avait pratiquement plus sonner pendant
une dizaine d'années donc ici dit je
vais acheter de la terre et puis comme
j'aime la terre est bien
moi les enfants ont toujours de quoi
manger et on a toujours des poireaux à
cueillir des pommes de terre il a acheté
une propriété en 53 des dès la fin de la
période noire il a commencé avec
quelques lapins annan et en 76 il avait
quand même 300 têtes de bétail et 15 15%
quoi donc c'est quand même il y avait
les deux mains y avait des missions il
ya vécu ressemble en fait ça faisait pas
mal que là aussi ça a été pour lui une
source d'angoissé parce qu'il y eu des
problèmes avec les agriculteurs avec
l'iphone et soeurs en 76 continue la
sécheresse par exemple la fnsea a dit
pas de pognon pour pour gabin pourquoi
pas parce qu'il ya de l'argent il a
besoin il rejoint de il n'a pas besoin
d'elle alors là il a mis le le domaine
en vente ont carrément critique tout de
suite avait tout de suite il a pris le
téléphone et la mine domaine en vente
ça ça lui avait asséné un sacré coup il
est mort quelques mois après et il est
mort quelques uns après cela annonce
elle l'avait salle avait achevé sa parce
qu'il a toujours essayé de rentrer dans
ce monde paysan et le monde paysan n'a
jamais voulu l'accueillir
ça a été c'est vrai que c'est à lui
qu'il serait vraiment son truc en plus à
lui ça mais c'était son truc de leur
entrée dans le monde présente dans le
monde du cinéma
il aimait bien bâtir faire des choses
alors au cinéma par exemple ils avaient
peur de demander de trop gros cachets
est-ce que c'est par peur de plus bosser
ou c'est par une espèce de morale
d'honnêteté comme ça plutôt par morales
ouais parce que bon c'est quelqu'un qui
avait travaillé à l'usiné quand il était
jeune quand même il avait 14 15 ans et
il a eu des moments très difficiles il
était d'une famille quand même très
pauvres et à partir du moment où il a
commencé à bien gagner sa vie
au tout début il a trouvé que c'était
bien qu'il n'avait pas besoin de plus et
puis pompe les cachets augmenté il est
arrivé à un certain plafond
et après il s'est dit bon j'arrête parce
que effectivement il ya des gars dans le
métier qui ont moins de chance que moi
et puis par pudeur j'ai pas envie de
demander trop d'argent c'est ça c'est
incroyable de se retrouver dans un film
il y avait un acteur qui était au même
niveau que lui par exemple au box office
le type gagner plus mais ça ça en dés
évidemment hystérique votre mère c'est
ce qu'on comprend évidemment est temps
qu'il a eu son agent
ça c'est bien ça s'est très bien passé
et puis après il après ça a été fini
s'est débrouillé tout seul et ce n'est
pas un homme d'affaires mon père et
votre mère alors que l'on parlait pas
beaucoup dans le livre florence ça doit
être terrible pour réaction qu'on a on
l'a vu quoi elle épouse le fringant jean
gab âges se retrouvent avec un petit
plus en plus papy l'argent bas ils n'en
demandent pas tellement ils dépensent
beaucoup d'argent dans cette propriété
que ça a coûté des fortunes vous
racontez vous raconter tout ça votre
mère
est-ce qu'elle avait envie de partir des
fois elle est allée parti une fois à huy
est là elle a pris son petit sac son
petit bagage et les parties pendant
trois quatre jours et après les revenus
puis lui il a rigolé il a dit tout et
est allié au bas je suis parti à l'hôtel
puis voilà mais il ya des moments où
c'était pas c'était pas évident ouais
mais je parle peu de ma mère mais oui
parce que ma mère était vivant et
j'avais pas suffisamment de recul
mon père j'ai du recul il ya quand même
très très longtemps un et ma mère était
là donc c'est très difficile de parler
de quelqu'un qui est là qui est vivant
il faut quand même est certain qu est ce
que vous pensez qu'elle a regretté
d'avoir épousé votre père ah non jamais
jamais jamais malgré que ce soit
quelqu'un de dents merdes en deux avec
des défauts épouvantable non non non
ah non quand elle quand il est parti
elle est restée 27 ans tout ça ah oui
non ça a été un manque terrible terrible
terrible alors gardin le bonheur d'une
certaine façon l'ua paraissait anormal
marché un peu comme ça mais ça reste
mutique ça m'a aidé non mais ça m'a aidé
parce que je me dis non maintenant je me
dis depuis je les lui ne fait pas ton
jean gabin parce que non ça c'est vrai
ça sert finalement le bonheur lui
apparaît c'est anormal c'est à dire par
exemple le matin dans la maison tout le
monde attendait le problème c'est dire
tout le monde et tout le monde
héééé madame gabin votre mère disais
mais qu'est ce qui va encore pouvoir
inventer aujourd'hui pour nous gâcher la
journée quoi donc tout moment la corde
et qui cela dit cela est effectivement
jusqu'au soir
ah mais oui il y avait toujours quelque
chose les jours où il y avait rien on
est inquiet on sait peut-être que ça va
arriver un peu plus tard
et puis on se couchait n'y avait pas eu
pour gâcher la journée
je me suis fait un peu comme ça alors
vous n'empêche que bon malgré tout vous
êtes heurté à lui ce qui est normal
quand une jeune fille en se heurte à son
père j'imagine que c'est courant mais
c'est aller un peu plus loin c'est à
dire qu'au moment de votre adolescence
vous allez était dépressive
vous avez eu ce que vous appelez dans le
bouquin un trou noir enfants tous les
cas vous ai pensé au suicide
c'était sa personnalité qui vous emmener
jusque là moi j'avais été élevé dans un
cocon aseptisé et je trouvais que en
fait la vie probablement devait être
autre chose est assez pop là j'ai
commencé à lire énormément j'ai commencé
à découvrir beaucoup de choses
les auteurs des philosophes tout ça et
je me disais mais ça n'a strictement
rien à voir avec la vie qu'on a un prix
et lui évidemment qui ne lisaient pas
donc j'ai essayé de parler avec lui de
ces choses-là on sait évidemment
plus que je foutais l'un l'autre et puis
ça a été de mal en pis et puis moi j'ai
c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me suis dit
mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
pourquoi est-ce que je suis là enfin
mouvement est tout un tas de questions
je serais incapable de vous dire
pourquoi mais ça a été quand même très
très loin mais je pense pas qu'il en
était lui-même responsable c'est moi qui
l'aï comment quand il vous a vu dans cet
état avec entre l'état était critique
on va quand même emmené chez le médecin
ouais bah oui parce que là c'était quand
même devenu
j'avais quand même maigri de 15 kilos en
un mois là il y avait du souci à se
faire quand même été assez dur avec vous
parce que par exemple le cheval qui nous
a promis pour le bepc vous l'avez pas la
voiture vous ne l'avez pas café c'est
terrible je trouve de promettre quelque
chose à un enfant et pas lui offrir
c'est si terrible parce que l'enfant il
y croit lui donc c'est assez émouvant de
là qu'on pourra compter ça pourquoi il
faisait ça je pense qu'il était il était
très très très maladroit et il disait
une chose un jour le lendemain c'était
autre chose il se rétractait il était
très très très difficile a scindé quand
même et comme en plus il a été très dur
dans son éducation qu'il fallait qu'on
se débrouille seul puisqu'on n'a jamais
eu d'argent de poche
moi j'ai travaillé comme vendeuse
pourquoi la rue de l'argent de poche et
je lui rendais la la monnaie au centime
près j'allais acheter le pari turf et il
fallait que j'en mets au centime frais
il ne voulait pas que je garde un
centime
donc j'étais habitué à ça un
effectivement main le jour où il m'a dit
battu rap à la voiture j'ai été déçu si
je me suis fait partie du personnage
mais le cheval gg quand même a fait mal
parce que ce cheval je l'attendais
depuis un an pourquoi c'était une
punition ou option n'est pas une piste
mais quoi qu'il avait peur comme un
accident
oui j'y disais que mais je pense que ça
devait aussi l'emmerdé qui est un cheval
comme ça improductifs à la maison tout
ce qui n'était pas productif des
produits de piscine pas de pénis oui on
avait on n'avait pas de décoration à la
maison tous les murs est aigri faut dire
que vous déménagiez tellement souvent
que le temps de décorer lui n est même
pas quel point les placards on rentrait
dans la cuisine maman disait mon mais la
vaisselle il avait oublié les placards 1
donc il n'y avait rien il y avait tout
ce qui n'était tout ce qui n'était pas
de rapport était totalement
prohiber de la maison ah oui oui alors
évidemment on vous raconter sa vie vous
raconter aussi votre aventure
professionnelle à vous c'est à dire vous
traversez quand même le cinéma français
des années 70 et 80 a participé à
beaucoup de beaucoup de grands films
notamment de guerre lasse avec notre ami
pierre arditi et puis un jour j'étais
sur moi aussi j'étais sûr évidemment pas
à la elle a craqué et un avant vous vous
croyez bien c'est lamentable mais c'est
lamentable
merci oui donc voila quoi un jour vous
craquer bah oui normal il est beau oui
et puis surtout très tendre moi qui
avais manqué de tendre et surtout vous
du jeu s'avère vite de long c'est
l'homme qui a été le plus tant le temps
avec moi toute ma vie mais c'est surtout
ça parce que bobo beau rendu très beauf
est libre mais bien sûr qu'il est les
jeudis n ya pas que ça parce que s'il y
avait eu plein beauté heureusement ce
n'est pas que ça un an la première fois
vous le voyez c'est aussi ce
extraordinaire c'est comme bodmer
quand elle est chère mais c'est qu'elle
va votre perdre décapotable rue du
faubourg saint-honoré avec marlene
dietrich vous un jour et sur un plateau
comme ça tout petit et vous voyez de
long et quelques années après à
pontarlier
et voila voila c'est 13 ans à 23 ans
voilà en dix ans il a fallu dix ans
voilà dix ans voilà ça s'appelle quitte
à avoir un père autant qu'il s'appelle
cap 1 avec un métier
alors le faire il avait une expression
s'était toujours dit non aux gamines
alors je vous faire une interview didon
gamine